c'est le grand salon des produits bio
qui rend compte de plus en plus de
succès même les cantines des écoles s'y
met voyez ce reportage au lycée liberté
de romainville ou le restaurant propose
régulièrement des menus bio dominique
d'humains manger bio c'est une devise ce
restaurant de lycées le chef et son
équipe préparent au moins une fois par
semaine un repas entièrement bio
au menu aujourd'hui poisson accompagné
de boulgour du blé concassé 350 repas
pour changer des habitudes tenaces c'est
un peu se battre contre les a priori sur
le bio parce que beaucoup de gens et en
particulier nos élèves ne savent pas
toujours exactement ce que veut dire bio
il y à il ya beaucoup d'à priori en fait
et il faut il faut faire preuve de
pédagogie
le message est plutôt bien perçu le bio
n'est pas forcément plus cher est
réservé à la diététique
moi je mets à continuer ça change très
prochainement elle avait donc les plus
grands parents qu'ils mangent
pareil quoi le calme
plus ça me change parce que je suis moi
je vois jamais vu ou presque est à la
cantine comme il en donne est souvent là
des légumes à manger chambre je prends
ma douche ou bien quand il y en a elles
imposent ont procédé jeudi à la tête de
l'alimentation les propos ci y voit des
avantages et parfois un message il ya
quasiment un choix partisans ont fait de
manger ce type de nourriture puisque
c'est aussi un refus de malbouffe
pour l'instant ces lycées sont
minoritaires une dizaine de régions des
restaurants scolaires bio il ya un
encouragement financier pour augmenter
leur nombre comme ici en ile de france
on a moins de problèmes d'absentéisme
mêmes paix sont absents idem quand même
manger à la cantine et je pense que le
bio a de l'avenir dans les
établissements scolaires puisque ça
aussi casse l'image un peu vieillotte de
la cantine des fruits et légumes qui
poussent sans engrais chimiques
les professionnels se disent prêts à
fournir selon la demande pour l'instant
la filière bio 16 structures
la demande est plutôt émerger mais si un
jour la demande venait à immerger
réellement je pense que la filière bio
serait en mesure de pouvoir produire
je pense qu'il faudra y mettre les
moyens manger bio est aussi associée au
plaisir de découvrir de nouvelles
saveurs
l'éveil à la curiosité passe par la
cuisine la conférence